vous avez un petit
copains et les matos 5 personnes il a
tué cinq personnes
il y a une traductrice alors
oui il y a une traductrice
elle s'appelle Corine
bonsoir Thierry donc vous parlez
portugais en fait
tous les vendredis
alors vous êtes brésilienne
je suis brésilienne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
votre histoire a l'air d'avoir été
inventé par un débutant du service
promotion et il va vraiment falloir
trouver des aspérités
pour donner un peu de matière à votre
biographie pour le moment c'est un petit
peu lisse donc va falloir que vous nous
aidiez parce qu'il faut quand même
rajouter un petit peu de d'épices à
cette biographie je compte sur vous je
compte sur vous Laurent aussi pour
m'aider alors vous êtes né à ita Bira
une petite ville brésilienne le 29 mai
1982 ensuite avec vos parents et votre
sœur cadette vous partez à Rio jusque là
rien d'extraordinaire
le directeur de l'agence de mannequin
élite vous voit il passe ses vacances au
Brésil
ils vous encourage à vous présenter au
concours élite look of the hear
jusque là rien d'extraordinaire en 96 et
14 ans vous arrivez première au concours
élite et élite vous signale un contrat
tout ça est très voilà et quand il
reçoit votre bouc que Paul Marciano le
patron des jeans Guess c'est qu'il a
trouvé la nouvelle figure de proue pour
sa marque voilà
c'est une accroche qui rit un truc
intéressant c'est déjà plus intéressant
vas-y fouille vous faites la pub de
Chanel la couverture des plus grands
magasins
couturiers sérieusement anabéatrice
c'est pas voilà c'est un peu c'est
formidable parce que vous êtes arrivé
mais c'est voilà
c'est un parcours classique
[Musique]
c'était très difficile j'étais très
jeune je n'avais pas d'expérience j'ai
grandi au fur et à mesure
j'ai appris à grandir très vite très
rapidement c'est une carrière où il y a
beaucoup de compétition il y a beaucoup
de monde sur le marché il y a de très
nombreux mannequins pour un défilé par
exemple il y a 4000 filles qui se
présentent et puis 20 places donc il
faut être très travailleuse il faut
travailler dur pour y arriver c'est vrai
que c'est formidable parce qu'elle a
fait
violée par mon père
non mais je sais pas par exemple vous
aimez bien le plat brésilien la comment
ça s'appelle voilà vous connaissez
Corine
s'il te plaît
[Rires]
champion du monde au foot
[Musique]
pour la presse il faudra trouver des
trucs un peu plus rock n' rolls
une légende ça se fait pas avec une
bière
demandez-lui s'il a quelque chose de
rock'n'roll à me raconter sur lui
alors raconte-moi
j'ai été violée par mon père à l'âge de
8 ans
très excitant quand on la voit comme ça
comment tu la trouves des Affaires
étrangères
[Musique]
vous avez un petit copain
il a tué cinq personnes
[Applaudissements]
ce qui serait génial moi je vais vous
dire belle comme vous êtes c'est qu'elle
tombe sur un prince sur un prince ou sur
un sur un roi veuf ou ce serait bien
pourquoi un roi veuve c'est plus facile
que marié
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors un Béatrice ça vous dirait de
faire une carrière de princesse ou de
Rennes
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas je n'ai rien
contre il y a des princes qui vous
plaisent
si vous étiez princesse est-ce que vous
coucheriez avec votre poissonnier
avec votre garde du corps si vous étiez
princesse
intime
j'y réfléchi je regarde ton visage et
j'y pense
un petit peu
pourquoi pas
vous laisser filer monsieur le
secrétaire d'État aux Affaires
étrangères mais je crois que vous allez
aller rapidement au Brésil
c'est il y a une mission il y a une
mission brésilienne
sont passionnantes et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu